and my mother she's just awful
she's been wishing death upon my
grandmother for seven years eight years
and they haven't talked him the whole
time and uh
at the funeral I did a eulogy and
everything for my grandmother I read it
and then at the she wasn't at the
funeral but she was waiting for us at
the graveyard and everybody knew she
hated her and when we put the casket
down she walks up to it Taps it tight
twice with a smile on her face that's to
say like you I'm glad you're gone
just a rotten person
and she's just been in and out of my
life
forever and I I don't know about
six seven months ago is when I finally
said I'm done trying because I'm just
too soft tough childhood oh that's an
awesome like my I mean even in my
adulthood my ex-wife right here let's
just start at the beginning all right so
you grew up where
New Haven Connecticut well I was born in
Yale New Haven Hospital but I grew up
like all over uh after I was born
we were living in East Haven for a
little bit Connecticut and then we moved
to North Haven Connecticut and that's
where I was until I was about 13 14. and
your parents might they were awful
they were
you know like my dad beat me every day
most of the time most of most days
mother allowed it beat her too
and this went on for how long
um well my mom
woke us up one day I was about 13 and he
went to work early because he was a
garbage man so he left at like maybe one
two three something like that and I
still remember laying in bed and I knew
when the lights from his car from his
truck were on the wall when he would
back out I would see the lights go and
then I would hear the motor like fade
away and I knew like I was safe you know
I knew he was like gone and I could like
breathe and go to sleep
and uh
so he he was I guess before either right
when I was born or right after I was
born he got arrested because he used to
drive a milk truck or something and he
tried luring a couple girls
like younger girls into his milk truck
and he got arrested and why my mother
stayed with him is beyond me I mean
after everything he did to us I don't
know why she stayed with him
um
and uh
he um one time I was in the shower and
he used to ride a motorcycle and uh
I was in the shower and he came in while
I was showering and all his friends were
over from his motorcycle friends were
over and he pulled me out of the shower
and thought it'd be funny to throw me in
front of everybody naked a kid and
I still remember the look on their faces
like what the hell is going on and I ran
back into the bathroom and he was just
like oh like he thought it was a joke
that's your dad that's my dad if if he's
even I have no clue
if he's even like that I don't know you
stayed home until when
so my mom woke us up at like
early in the morning and she said get up
we're leaving we're getting away from
him I said okay and a buddy of mine
and his dad she had talked to them
I it was a kid friend of mine that I
hung out with and it was she asked his
dad and he came over and drove a truck
and we moved everything out and
um we moved to North Brantford and um
she ended up taking him back again
but he was like cheating on her finding
condoms she was Finding condoms and then
one night like I remember he said he was
he was on the computer it's like right
around when American online came out and
he was on the computer I don't know if
it was when it came out but it was like
kind of new and he was on the he was on
the computer and he just gets up and
goes I'm going to a Yankees game I'm
like oh cool can I go and he's like
absolutely not no blah blah I never
understood why obviously when I grew up
and I thought about that I figured it
out that he was probably going to cheat
on her but um they ended it pretty
quickly again after that and then she
met a got another guy and then I was out
the door because me and that guy didn't
get along
so I've been living on all my friends
couches I've been on my own since I was
14.
um
you know one time uh
with my father he burned my Christmas
presents because I was bad uh I have I
had a tooth missing if you look at like
pictures of me when I was a kid I'm
always missing one tooth first it was
because of hockey then they put it back
in emergency I remember I had to go late
at night they put it in and
one day I had my socks down and he
yelled at me to pull him up I said no so
he smashed my face into the garage floor
and that tooth came out again
uh
he uh
one time
um
he told us that he had killed our cats
we had four cats he and they were gone
one day and he told us all that he
killed them
so I don't know how long it went by but
a little bit of time went by and uh
he
my brother noticed it we were pulling
out we had a trailer on our property
like a pull-along trailer and my brother
noticed one of the cats sticking their
head out like up through the window
so he went through the window
to get open the door so we can get the
cats out so he was just lying to us the
whole time just to mentally with us
um that's just who he was and he uh
eventually they split he moved down to
Florida and
um
my
like I said I'm a softy my uh
he called me one day I used to work at a
bowling alley on the machines and he
found out I worked there somehow so he
calls me one day
and um he says I'm doing good I've
changed blah blah
softy I said okay he's like I want to
come up and see you for your birthday
I said okay
so he came up he came to the bowling
alley where I was working at we talked
he seemed okay
he gave me some money for my birthday I
can't remember how much but he gave me a
little bit of money for my birthday
and that was that he went down he told
me he wanted me to move down there with
him I said I'll think about it
and I was on probation after my mom
kicked me out
um
I was on probation because I was getting
into a lot of trouble all the time
already in the drugs smoking crack when
I was 16. heroin at 18 17 18 something
like that anything I can get my
hands on honestly
but Kraken heroin were pretty bad and um
so I went to my mom's house because I
had to do my probation piss test at her
house and it was court ordered
so I walked in and she's on the phone
laughing and like I'm like what the hell
is going on she's like oh just talking
to your father's girlfriend I'm like
from Florida and she's like yeah she's
like yeah she you know they got into a
fight and he broke a bunch of her ribs
and burned all her clothes on the front
lawn
I'm like what the man so
a little bit of time went by he called
me at my work as soon as I heard his
voice he's like Michael and I'm like why
the are you calling me and he's
like oh they're all lying Michael
they're all lying Michael I'm like
they're always lying dad they're
always lying huh so my last words to
Omar I hope you die and then he
died he was on his motorcycle and he
crashed into a jersey barrier and he was
a vegetable and I remember my mother
told me that me my mother and my brother
had to sign something to pull the plug
and I didn't want to sign it I told my
mother him let him rot I don't care
he tortured me my whole life so then she
said Michael
now this is when I was up on
heroin she says Michael if you sign this
you're getting twenty thousand dollars I
said give me the pen
so I signed it so
I got the twenty thousand dollars and I
that up so bad I just I blew it
all and I kicked myself in the ass for
it every single day
uh I wish I had had it now obviously but
I that all up just like
everything else I had done in my life
but
um he you know I would be at my friend I
lived on all my friends couches so I'd
be like at their house and
like I'd see I'd be with them for like
holidays or for whatever and I'm like I
had to have a good time because there's
pros to being a kid that young on your
own like you get to party your ass off
and nobody stop you so that's a
pro but the cons were
you know you're sitting there with all
these families because I lived with a
lot of people and
it's not your family you know you're
there you're having fun but you're like
still in in my head like
this sucks you know like I don't
have my own family to do this with
they're like like I can't go even still
to this day I'm 41. you know I can't go
sit down and I have never been able to
go sit down with like my dad or my mom
and like figure out a problem or look
for advice it was always my friend's
parents those were my my parents you
know do you feel like the childhood that
you went through
impacts you still today
it taught me how not to be because I
have a daughter and I would do anything
for her and I have done a lot for her it
seems like your personality might be
like you almost a reaction to your dance
yeah yeah totally without a doubt um a
lot of people like follow in those
footsteps but I hated it I don't know
the reason I think I haven't is because
I hated it so much through the whole
time of going through it that I just
knew it was wrong the whole time you
know
and uh with my daughter you know I'll do
anything for her I'll protect her until
the day I die and I've been clean
you know
years now five six years something like
that but
you know it took me a while to get to
that because even I up with my
daughter you know I mean I never lost
her with custody or anything like that
but I was doing drugs while I had her I
up you know I up big time
I don't really tell too many people this
but I overdosed and she was
there in the house
luckily nothing happened because of it
because everybody else in the house was
silver
but
I up and that was the biggest
up of my life
and I still to this day
I use I mean I'll always have to cope
with that but I use that as like
my staying clean fuel I guess like I
don't want to go through that ever again
luckily she was so young that she's not
gonna remember it but I will
and
you know I had a teller recently that
you know it happened because
me and my ex-wife get along real really
good now
um we're good co-parents together now
but we had a lot of go on and
I was lied to for a year because she was
going out with somebody and
I had found out that he was on the sex
offender registry
so I immediately went to the courthouse
and filed for an emergency order and
it took me three years and two trials to
keep him away
but
it's all behind us now so I try to
forget about it and she's doing what
she's supposed to do she's a good mom
she takes care of her kid she loves her
very much and my daughter loves her mom
very much and that's what it's about you
know I try to like
make sure that my kid is happy and I'm
not going to have her have a resentment
on me
because I took her mom away or something
like that I you know she's 13 now she's
well she's 12 going on 13 and she's old
enough to make that decision on her own
and who she wants to be with and
you know we have her 50 50. and um
she loves her mom you know I was
there you know there was a full year
where I didn't know that this guy was on
that that list and
ECF called me and told me and I
immediately went and did something about
it but
I uh you know it's about my daughter and
she wants to see her mom and she wants
to be around her mom so
I'm not going to stop that
and like I said me and her mom are
getting along really good now and her
mom's taking her when she's supposed to
and she has her actually more sometimes
if I need her to take her an extra day
or she needs me to take an extra day you
know we work it out
so things are good there
um
and I'm happy about that and Ray Lynn's
my daughter's happy about that
um
and then
getting into my mother
like I said she my grandmother had just
passed away a month ago about a month
ago and
my mother
hated her still hates her always has
constantly wishing death upon her
and for her to show up at the graveyard
not the funeral but at the graveyard
then smile and slap that coffin twice
was just everybody there knew she hated
her so she I she was trying to get a
reaction out of me that's what she was
trying to do and
you know it didn't work I didn't let her
achieve that I just kept my mouth shut
because I knew everybody that was at
that graveyard knew how she felt about
her mother so she made herself look like
a complete psycho by doing that
and then she always tries to reel me
back in she called me
actually on one of those
the second trial it was a two-day trial
with that whole thing
and I hadn't talked to her for a while
because my brother was getting married
and my brother we haven't lived together
since I was 14 years old you know he
don't give a about me he don't care
about his his niece at all he does you
know so he got married and he
I'm sure because I'm his brother and
that's the only reason asked me to to go
so I said okay maybe this is the start
of us having a relationship or something
so I
went and got fitted for my tux and my
daughter was like why do I have to go to
this I'm like he's your uncle she's like
he doesn't care about me he doesn't call
me he doesn't do anything for me and I'm
like
you make a good point
so I called my brother and I was like
listen like the fact that I even had to
do this was ridiculous but I called him
I was like do you think you can like
call Ray here and there and like try to
get to know her a little bit like I want
her to go to your you know your wedding
I'd really like her to go
he said okay then you never did so I
waited weeks and he never did so I got
to the point I'm like I'm not going
forget it I'm not going and I don't
blame my kid for not wanting to go
either so I canceled my my talks because
I went and got fitted for it and
everything I canceled it my mom you know
flipped out on me
and then the second day of the trial I
hadn't talked to her for a while and I
was saying to my girlfriend I'm like she
ain't gonna call me see how things are
going and pretty much right when I said
that the phone rang and it was her and
I'm like wow so I pick it up I'm like
hello she's like so what's going on and
I'm like oh this they said this the
judge said that she's like oh Michael
that's getting old are you going to the
wedding or not
I'm like that's it I'm like don't even
bother calling me again I'm like I'm
done with you that's it
Choice words and then uh
she
about a month after that calls me and
she's giving me a sob story that she has
cancer
and
I pretty much told her I don't
care I said I'm sorry you have cancer I
wouldn't wish that upon anybody but I'm
done letting you pull your on
me I'm not you're not you're not reeling
me in like this again you have
left me for men when I was 14 going in
and out of juvie getting hooked on all
kinds of drugs getting arrested I mean
it was just my life was a complete
show do you wish your childhood was a
white picket fence perfect family one or
do you feel like what you went through
has made you a better person
I guess I'm
I mean it sucks but what what happened
and everything but you know I still
struggle because of it you know like I I
live paycheck to paycheck so some ways I
do in some ways I don't I wish I had
like that childhood so I could have like
I had to emancipate myself when I was 16
years old to stop the courts from
with me because the great state
of Connecticut court system kept sending
me to my father who has beaten me and
then I would go to long or I would go
get locked up overnight go to Long Lane
and he would get off scot-free beat the
out of me and nothing that would
ever happen to him they kept sending me
to him and then he would get sick of me
and drive me to my mother's house and
then she would get sick of me and they
would both call on me and say I ran away
while they were physically bringing me
back and forth and I'm getting arrested
out of my school in front of everybody
and
I had to go get emancipated to stop the
courts from with me and my
grandmother actually took me to do it
and uh so that's like
it's just one thing after the next where
I try to like get ahead and I don't I'm
I mean my grandmother told me forever
that she had money for me
in her
um in her will
and a family member I'm not gonna say
who but a fan not my mother but a family
member
I'm pretty sure me out of that
because I haven't heard anything and
every time I she loves to control me uh
and she like uses things like that to
control me she has a time share in Cape
Cod and she pretty much uses that on me
every single year because she knows that
my daughter is going to want to go but
my kid's smart now she's like sees
what's going on and she's like Dad she
came to me the last time and she's like
Dad we don't have to go she's like I see
what she's doing to you and we don't
have to go
I was like you're the coolest kid ever
man you know and then while we were
there because I can't go I can't afford
it for the whole week I go for like a
couple days and we don't even do
anything we just swim in the pool and
hang out in the room so
that family member had called me and
she's like I want to treat you to a
whale watch I'm like wow I'm like okay
that's cool so I told my daughter and
she's like I'm scared to go on a boat
I'm like okay I'll tell her and she's
like well my offer is for a whale watch
so if you don't want to do that then too
bad if you want you can borrow 200 from
me I was like I'm all set I'm not taking
that you kidding me I know what comes
with that
so I didn't even take and we just we
left the next day
so it's just constant from
everybody in my family like my friends
are my family my girlfriends
family is my family like I'm so lucky
with my girlfriend because the bond that
they have that she has with my daughter
man it's amazing they're just the best
of friends and
you know it makes me really happy it's
great she's really really good with her
um but I don't want like I wish
my goal is to like leave something for
my daughter so she doesn't have to grow
up like I did in a sense of struggling
so much
um
and I was hoping to do that with what
happened you know it sucks to say but I
mean we knew it was going to happen but
my plan was to do something like I
screwed it up once like I wanted a
chance to do it again and
that ain't gonna happen so I think about
it every day like what am I going to be
able to do and I've tried like doing
things what are you doing for work now I
work full time
um I work your shipping receiving
how old do you know 41 41. do you see
any similarities in you and your
Dad or Mom
sometimes genetic
yeah personality or physical or whatever
a lot me and my mom butted heads so much
when we were younger because we're a lot
alike
and my father it's more I don't know
because
the guy that could be my father I look a
lot like him too when I look at pictures
of my sometimes I look at pictures of my
father and I'm like there's no way that
somebody else in my body he looks just
like we look alike then I look at the
pictures of the other guy
and I'm like we look alike who's the
other guy
so when my mom
my mom was married to somebody else
she met my father
divorce that guy
and got with my father but while she was
divorcing that guy she was pregnant with
me
and
possibly my no she was pregnant with me
with while she was being but while she
was being divorced from that other guy I
see so my grandmother had told me that
about him like a couple months before
she actually passed so he might not be
your father and I was just like great so
I tracked the guy down he's like well
off it's really well off
um he owns a business
so that made me like not want to talk
call him even more because I don't want
the guy to think I'm like trying to get
something from him
but I had to know so I I found them and
I I called them and he remembered my mom
and remembered everything
and he had said that while they were
getting divorced
his
lawyer wanted to bring up how she was
pregnant with me
and he told his lawyer to leave it alone
so his words to me were I'm not your
father
not possible
and that's pretty much it he was nice
about it
and he talked to me for a little bit
about 10 minutes or so so he like you
know took a little time to talk to me
about it but
I don't know I always wonder that now
like ever since I got told that it's
like is that why my father hated me so
much and beat the out of me all the
time and did everything that he did to
me like is that why
and nobody's telling me
um
the only person
that probably knows is my mother and she
ain't gonna tell me
so
I don't know I'll probably never find
out
um
and then you know drugs were
man they were a big part of my life they
like I I had nothing else to do you know
I was homeless for a while I was living
out of my truck because it was just
easier for me
you know I was robbing stores I was
robbing people
um I was robbing scrap yards
um
breaking into cars
you name it
New Haven was
I like going back here and there to
visit but I just can't be there's too
many memories
and uh
you know
smoke like sometimes when I think about
that like starting smoking crack at 16
years old it's like you're so young you
know I mean I know kids start earlier
than that these days too but still
like that's young and
I did a lot of hallucinogenics too I did
anything I could get my hands on
honestly
um
you know I just
that's why I wish things were different
because like
all my stimulus checks that I got I
spent on my car I've been driving around
in a car with no heat for three years I
don't have any heat in that car and it's
like I can't I came down to the
catalytic converter
uh
going on it so it came down to twelve
hundred dollars of stimulus money to fix
that
which needed to be fixed
or be comfortable
so I had to do that
I do as much work on my car as I can
myself I do my own brakes
um I do my own oil changes I just did
some sway bar links to come up here
um wheel bearings I do everything I can
myself everything that I can like myself
but some stuff I can't do like I can't
do a catalytic converter I can't I know
it's the heater core that's wrong with
the car and I can't do that I don't the
one I don't have the tools to do it and
two I wouldn't know what I was doing in
the first place
so I have a process for it though I'll
put a space heater in there and run an
extension cord out in the mornings and
I'll leave it on with the car running
for like 45 minutes and I'll take that
out and I have a little plug-in lighter
that I give when my daughter's with me
I'll give her that with the heater and
she like puts her blanket over herself
and stays warm like that
so I have a process to do it but that's
the one thing I've always been as like a
Survivor and figuring stuff out and
trying to make things work
which like
you know keeps you sharp but I wish I
didn't have to do all that
you know it's like I feel like no matter
how hard I try I always end up going
back a peg
and
um
it's just how it is you know all I know
is
I have to stay clean
that's number one and I'll always be
number one because I have thought about
that too like if I was doing drugs with
everything that happens in my life
Jesus that would be a show
and
I just have to
I just have to stay clean and make sure
that I set that example for my kid
and honestly if my daughter wasn't in my
life I'd either be dead or in jail
it'd be one or the other
so and that's 100 if that kid wasn't in
my life I'd be dead or in jail
probably did
Mike what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
in your life
be good to the people that are good to
you
that's probably the most important thing
I mean obviously there's other things
but I mean speaking like
you know from the heart
like I've had a lot of people be there
for me you know so
and they know that I got their back no
matter what
and like I said my friends are my family
my girlfriend's family is my family
these are all people that have treated
me better than my own family I literally
have nobody from my blood
so
I'll always be the black sheep and
that's fine
but
I guess be good to the people that are
good to you
obviously stay clean
that's like always got to be number one
because if I don't stay clean then I
lose everything I lose my place I'll
lose my daughter
which is the most important thing
you know I lose my job everything will
go
so
that would be the most important thing
is to just
stay clean and
treat the people
that you love and that treat you good
treat them good all right
Mike thank you so much for sharing your
story yep no problem wish you guys lots
of luck thank you thanks man